recently scientists have discovered a  self-tuning properties in the nervous  system  inside the brain neurons communicate  with each other by firing action  potentials if the neurons are firing  more than usual it might lead to  excitability and this hyper excitability  can lead to epileptic sheasers  so it turns out  inside our brain there must be  mechanisms which can prevent this kind  of hyper excitability  so professor gina durgiano at brandeis  university came up with this theory  called self-tuning neuron  in this theory neurons can understand  their firing rate with an activity  sensor any increase or decrease in  activity is sensed by this sensor and it  can interact with molecular networks to  bring the activity to a baseline or  steady state level and thereby  preventing excitotoxicity mediated  damages  how cool is that right subscribe for  more